the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I guess I'll start now since uh I think
this might be the crowd because most
people are probably sleeping after the
sprint submission deadline where most
people up at 6:00 a.m. most well most if
not all all right so my name is Corey
I'm from the winning team last year and
what I really want to do today is kind
of give a complete information dump so
this this convert this lecture will
almost seem like a stream of conscious
but these are the things that throughout
all of our years at battlecode are the
things we really wish we had got in
lecture but never actually got so so my
goal is hopefully to give kind of the
most relevant hopefully like the most
applicable lecture to the nitty gritty
details of like the day-to-day things
that you're doing in battlecode in order
to make your bot better and try to
improve your performance against the
other teams
so whatever competitive edge you can
glean from this hopefully propel
yourself to the top of the ladder
so just to give a little bit of
background about myself I've been in
three teams since oh 10 the first two
years were were kind of meh but in 2012
we were finally able to win win the
entire thing with with my teammates and
paying height oh and Justin and each
year was was quite different because of
the people you work with so what I want
to do is give a lot about our 2012
experiences and kind of explain the
various choices we did the the tricks
and techniques we did in order to give
ourselves an edge over the other team
and I also want to give special thanks
to these four teams in particular gun
face my or kondaiah bellman-ford the
stream drunk asaurus and toothless just
know that like battlecode is not done in
a vacuum and you learn from all the
other teams and so these teams were
particularly helpful that our team
learned from that our team collaborated
with that we were able to share code
bases and learn from each other etc so
just a pre foot preface everything
we're the ones fun gamers is the one
responsible for the spec this year so if
any of you guys have problems with it
you can't really blame max or Steven you
have to blame us so any cards for like
nerfing Opie whatever
it comes to us we made a lot of huge
changes here just because we wanted to
mix up the game a little bit and also we
wanted to make it a little bit easier
for people to start off code bases and
get running players I don't know how
many of you guys played in 2010 or even
2011 but the amount of code required to
get even a simple bot up and running was
enormous so in 2010 because you couldn't
actually attack a unit until you had
equipped a gun on a robot it took almost
like 1 to 2 days worth of code base
before you could even get a robot moving
and attacking simultaneously so what we
did a lot was simplify a huge number of
things to make it a lot more
higher-level strategic control so no
walls attacking is completely automatic
we removed directionality I don't know
how many of you guys played last year
but this one's like pretty big there's
no robotic or robot directionality we
added in shared vision globale
broadcasting and known map so does
anyone just do most people enjoy this
changes at least people who have played
it in previous years yeah well we're
really excited at least about in
particular having having the map
completely known and a global
broadcasting because it allows like an
unprecedented level of robot
communication this year so you can now
instead of having a bunch of almost
completely autonomous robots with very
limited broadcasting you can have
coordinated attacks you know the map you
can design your strategy based on the
map we rather then rather than wandering
around for a hundred to a thousand
rounds not knowing where to go getting
stuck behind voids etc um the no walls
is also very interesting what we found
in previous years is is contestants will
sometimes just if the map is really
stupid or really [ __ ] what will end
up happening is you just watch for 3,000
rounds both people stuck in their base
because of this like really interesting
concave of walls that prevents the
people from getting out and actually
engaging each other so with no walls you
can actually basically control the
battlefield you can defuse mines you can
add your own walls you can prevent your
enemies from attacking you can like
create kind of you you can bend the
battlefield to your will which we
thought was really exciting especially
because you're no longer completely
screwed over if the
Mapp wasn't what you expected so to
begin I want to emphasize that
battlecode is a trade-off of time so
this is like the this is what battlecode
ultimately comes down to you have three
to four weeks to basically implement an
entire bot okay and in these three to
four weeks you have to decide what is
most important if you spend your time on
the wrong thing you will not win you
have to spend your time where it matters
and in particular I want to say that
results to effort very very highly
between what you choose to spend your
time on so one of the most important
things to spend your time on is is
attack micro if you can win every
engagement you will win the game it
doesn't matter if they're higher level
strategy if you always win the
engagement you will beat their army
straight up no matter what okay
next if swarm code if your swarm moves
together you will usually win the
engagement if you have better swarm code
your attack micro can be a little bit
off but you'll still end up engaging
with larger numbers and winning the
fight and winning fights wins games the
navigation code allows you to actually
get to the enemy swarm and defeat them
and then there is some high-level
strategy that you can't make completely
wrong choices but but once again if you
have good attack micro you can make
questionable high-level strategies but
still win every engagement so the way
I'm gonna structure this lecture is I'll
have various like tags that there are
certain things that apply to novices
there are certain things that apply to
to advanced players and then there are
certain things that apply to expert
players this is also comes down to a
trade-off of time if you have four
people maybe you want to consider doing
some of the more advanced tricks and
tactics but if you only have say if
you're working solo you only have two
people you want to spend your time where
it matters so don't spend time
implementing things that give you very
tiny marginal advantages when you could
say be focusing on your attack micro and
win all the battles rather than saving
maybe like one or two byte codes per per
iteration
so the first first first off to do well
in battle code you really have to know
the spec and I know like we've been
really bad at keeping the specs up today
and there have been typos but hopefully
by now
everything has mostly been standardized
and corrected and all the typos and then
you guys didn't really like our
diffusion diffusion joke so we we
changed the word diffusion to diffusion
so that you guys didn't think I was the
type of one we were stupid so quick
quick quick quick quiz what's the base
spawn rate something call it out ten all
right nice what's the cost for three
suppliers cumulative what was that I
think I heard it over there sixty right
because starts off with 10 for the first
supplier then the cost is a cost as
additive so 20 20 and then 30 into 60 60
total cost for three suppliers what what
is the spawn rate with three suppliers
okay it's eight so total cost of three
suppliers is the spot the spawn rate of
three suppliers is eight per round
because it is cut kind of a curve the
first supplier will get you down to nine
the second supplier will get you down to
eight and the third supplier is actually
the first supplier that doesn't bring
you down another point because it's
rounded to the nearest integer even so
in terms of unit spawned at what round
is the first supplier break even
so these are all like critical numbers
that if you know you can kind of gain
the spec to your advantage plus close
the first supplier breaks even at what
round if I get one supplier I have one
turn spawn reduction which means I
break-even in terms of units that what
round I sacrifice one unit to get the
supplier so I'll break even when I get
back that extra unit which is at 90
rounds so so so the first supplier
breaks even at 90 rounds so these are
like key numbers they may be tweaked in
the future but if you always have a
sense of all these numbers you can kind
of make good high-level decisions about
what you should be building and what you
shouldn't be building at at the
beginning of the game so the beginning
of the game is like very key what we did
was you have an excess of energy so you
have a choice like in Max's lecture
yesterday of whether to build generators
or suppliers and if you know roughly at
what time these things break even or at
what time you gain the marginal
advantage you can decide when to
attacker when not to attack so know the
specs that that's it's very key second I
want to say testing is probably the most
important thing second from spending
your time in the correct place because
you don't actually know if you're
spending in through your time the
correct place unless you're actually
testing the code so - as a high level
you want to write multiple distinct bots
so I know a lot of teams maybe just have
like a single bot lineage but our team
we wrote we wrote like 10 to 12
different BOTS each one with like
different strategies and sometimes we
wrote BOTS completely from scratch when
we thought we had a really cool strategy
so last year there were like flying
units so we thought well it would be
kind of cool maybe if we could have
units that only if we had a base that
only spawned flying units and we did a
little bit of theory crafting in her
head and it turned out the dps was like
marginally higher but the problem is
once we tried to implement it we found
out the actual problems with the flier
strategy was that we couldn't sustain
the unit's because
the way that energy transfer was done
last year and we weren't actually able
to coordinate they attack well enough to
gain that theoretical DPS so so testing
is extremely important wins of course
beat theory crafting so you can what
even knowing the specs and knowing the
break off times you have to be able to
implement them in practice otherwise the
theory doesn't pay off the scrimmage
server is your ally and testing and then
you always want to prioritize writing
behaviors over spending a lot of time
doing framework code because the
behaviors are what you're actually
testing not the framework one thing that
novices make the mistake of is they're
always afraid of ranked games so has
everyone in here played at least one
ranked game yes so what I want to say is
it's really a problem more with novices
than with the people who've been doing
battle code for a long time and the
reason this is is because sometimes you
submit a bot and you're afraid that it's
MIT it's maybe not so good or there's
some problems with it or that your code
is gonna do badly and you're gonna lose
points but what it gains you is by
scrimmaging often you will always know
what the top teams are up to and the
thing is if you do unranked top teams
actually have no incentive to accept
your match and you'll never know what
they're actually doing so the trade-off
is a top team if they beat if if they
beat you in a ranked game they'll
actually gain eloah points but you
actually gain something from that you
gain the understanding of how the top
team is microing the kind of high level
strategy the top team is doing and also
any any tips or tricks or small things
that you you can glean from those games
to perform better in your next spot
iteration actually if you send an
unranked game to one of the top teams
it's actually a lose-lose situation for
them because a they have the probability
of losing a lot of points to you and B
they're also giving away their
high-level strategy so for the top like
five teams what at least in years past
if you sent them an unranked match
they'd cancel it and send you back a
ranked match because it's there's almost
no advantage for them to accept these
ranked matches so don't be afraid of
sending ranked games especially against
top teams because that's where you're
going to learn the most about how you
can improve your bot
another thing that sometimes beginners
get wrong is that your codebase is
actually more than your bot there is a
huge infrastructure that we built at
least around our bot last year that was
not just the simple that was not just
robot player and everything surrounding
robot player so one of the easiest
things you can do is you can make custom
maps every year when we start battle
code we always make this map on the
right we call it planes because there's
absolutely nothing on it the the that
the plans for this year we have like a
few encampments in the middle just to
test like baked basic encampment capture
code but what planes really allows you
do to do is it allows you to perfect
your attack micro and make it so that
you're not worrying about like advanced
pathfinding you're just making sure you
can win engagements because as I said
like attack micro is so important
winning engagements wins games so spend
time actually making custom maps I know
we don't really have a map editor out
this year so if you make like a map
editor to make a bunch of custom maps
test your pathfinding test your attack
micro there's there's so many small
things you can do to test your BOTS very
fast a few small things that you guys
may have also not known is with custom
maps you can actually declare units to
be pre spawned on the map so in the top
right you're allowed to declare symbols
you can actually set up unit formations
to quickly test different scenarios and
just by hitting play and repeatedly
running it you can tweak whatever
heuristics you're running in order to
make sure that your code is actually
running correctly and then making custom
maps is also extremely good for testing
pathfinding so you can spawn a map with
a unit already in the center and then
just hard code in and an end point to
nav two and then see if your navigation
is running any better than it was before
this is kind of like a little a bit
expert thing but we spent a lot last
year trying to game the scrimmage server
a little bit so Justin wrote kind of a
scraper that scrapes the rankings every
five minutes and determines
winning to who if you guys are just
starting out don't don't worry about
this too much but what this allowed us
to do actually was it allowed us to know
which teams were actually rising quickly
which teams had maybe changed their
strategy and it allowed us to kind of
target our ranked matches because we
would see oh this team won like three
games in rapid succession we want to see
what they're doing or oh this team maybe
like dropped four games and we probably
don't really need to send them a ranked
match because they're probably not doing
anything different than than what they
used to be doing but once again this is
a custom tool that was written outside
of the framework of just our Eclipse
project with our battle code bot that
allowed us to gain like a small
competitive edge over everyone else this
the current ladder stats ranking system
is actually I think Justin posted about
it in the forums he's actually running
it publicly for you guys this year so if
you want to take take a peek and just
use his code are our old one actually
recorded elo elo gains and losses so we
could see like whether a team like
gained like one or one point or whether
they gained ten so if a team gains like
30 points in a single match that's like
a warning bow all right because it means
they're doing something drastically
different and you want to know what
they're up to this tool was another tool
we borrowed from gun face from 2011
it's basically a mask scrim tester so
the scrimmage server actually is not the
only place that you can mask scrim you
can also build your own custom masks
criming framework which is what gun
fates did in 2011 and what we co-opted
from them in 2012 so what this actually
allows us to do is it allows us to test
in house our own BOTS against each other
so you know how I said we wrote like 10
to 12 distinct bots what we would do was
we could actually characterize which one
was strictly superior to all the other
bots by pitting them against each other
in thousands of matches so if you'll see
here what this did was a we had a total
win counter so we could submit jobs to
our cue server the queue would run like
50 60 matches on every single known map
in the scrimmage to ranking and then of
course it takes some time to compute we
actually we borrowed a bunch of XVM
machine
to continuously run this in the
background but you'll see here every
single one of our tagged releases we're
actually pitting it against each other
last year we would consider a bot good
if we could beat our older iterations
like 90 percent of the time and until we
could get kind of that 90 percent mark
we would consider them about to be equal
because some some small change and maybe
like the random generator or whatever
would affect the outcome of the match
but but again the most drastic
improvements when you see like when you
see like 30 100 though those are from
usually from micro improvements where
one bot will just the two armies will
collide and one bot will just obliterate
the other one even with equal numbers
but these sort of things running the
mass grim you can really really get a
sense of this is an expert level kind of
thing if you don't have if you have one
person you're not going to blow your
time
wait writing like a scrimmage based
system but if you have maybe three or
four people you could take a day or so
to maybe try to repurpose the old 2012
math scrim tester which is on github by
the way to get it working with the 2013
game one thing that hasn't really been
covered ever I think is kind of the the
bytecode system in detail I think in
battle code and this is a very key part
of battle code and yet it's always kind
of glossed over the you'll hear like the
lecturers say you should use less by
codes
they're like the less byte codes you use
the more units you can have but what
does actually what does that actually
mean and how does that actually
translate into implementation so I'll
skip ahead and just give a brief
overview of the JVM for people who are
unfamiliar with it so the java virtual
machine is a stack based system so what
it basically means is if you're familiar
with x86 or whatever there are no
registers there's just a giant stack and
you can imagine it as values get pushed
on the stack and popped off of the stack
and that's how computation is done by
codes are when you write your Java it
gets compiled into something called byte
codes and byte codes are very similar to
assembly except they work on this
stacked Bay
system and the way the stack is is you
have this operand stack which is your
current stack of values so it if you
imagine like pre freak operations I can
push or postfix operation so I can push
two values on the stack
I can call add and it would pop off the
result right so so if you imagine that
JVM is kind of working like that it's
very similar but there's also an array
of local variables up top and these are
indexed by a number so actually stack
operands can operate directly onto the
array of variables that are that are
globally accessible and then there's
also a global constants pool that byte
codes can can operate on so that this is
just an example online and if you want
to read more there's a URL down here but
what happens is you compile your java it
gets turned into byte codes and then
each byte code is actually stepped
through by our instrumentation engine
and that's what you're getting counted
on so when someone says you're using
like 10 byte codes it actually means
that the high-level Java call you made
is being turned into 10 individual
atomic steps on the JVM and you're
getting penalized for each one of these
atomic steps that this leads to a lot of
interesting things so there's a very
classic kind of loop structure in
battlecode I here this is so classic
actually that Dropbox's code base is
littered littered with this structure so
it looks like kind of a normal for loop
but if you look closely you'll notice
that we don't even have a third
parameter what this is is it for I is
equal to the length of the array
decrement until you're greater than zero
and it's reversed from maybe like the
way normal computer science would teach
it to you but there's a particular
reason we do it this way and that's
because we're actually bytecode hacking
so what happens is Java is similar kind
of like there's there's legacy in that
in computers testing against zero is
actually an operation that comes up very
often in most branch and most branch
conditions you're testing against
like boolean czar testing against zero
etc so there's actually a special
bytecode for testing against zero and
then also when you're doing the
comparison you don't want to be
recomputing say messages dot length
every single time so this actually has a
net effect of saving byte codes because
you can't actually write the byte codes
out but you can predict what the
compiler will spit out and because
battlecode is not run as as just-in-time
compiler agen actually the bytecode is
stepped through exactly as its outputted
this ends up with a net savings of a few
byte codes so if you'll see down here
this is like the classic way you would
write a loop that you might learn in
intro to computer science for for AI is
equal to zero I is less than your
terminating condition increment I what
happens here is because you want to
compare AI every round two messages
length computing messages that lengths
is actually a separate compare operation
with loading the actual object loading
the actual array object whereas in our
our initial version what we've done here
is we've set the index variable actually
to the final value and we're comparing
against zero which is a single byte code
operation so what happens is that this
is a net savings of like two by codes
okay to buy codes actually might not
seem like a lot but if you're say
looping through a hundred objects that
that's 200 byte codes saved in the
entire loop and that's two whole sense
functions so you could sense that's two
whole like global sense functions with
with the radius and the location that
that's actually pretty big so it's
saving 200 byte codes can mean that you
might have additional data on the
battlefield or you can loop through one
additional object when you're trying to
compute a heuristic for map locations or
for Army positions and this actually
gives you like a small marginal
competitive edge over the other team
especially this year when byte codes
also translates to energy so saving byte
codes gives you back more energy more
energy translates to more units if all
your units are saving like 500 by codes
per turn that that adds up over time
especially with the decay rate
so with bike codes you'll also end up
wanting to implement your own data
structures so I don't know if you guys
have tried using the native Java data
structures like hash set array cue set
etc but we actually penalize you for the
internal calls that Java makes in those
data sets
so if Java Java likes to be very safe so
a lot of the thread safe code will like
check to make sure like another thread
is not trying to mutate the data or that
there's there's not a lock on the data
etc so the thread safe code actually
ends up hurting you a lot because
there's a lot of excess byte codes that
gets called so for instance a single
hash set iterator getnext getting a
value from a hash set worst case is to K
by codes for a single call which is
absurd because you can implement a hash
set yourself with an array and maybe
like 200-300 byte codes if you custom
write it so what ends up happening is a
lot of people will make what's called
fast data sets so we wrote like a fat
fast hash set a fast ArrayList and these
are all custom based on arrays that we
could index directly into and pay a very
minimal byte code cost in order to get
very complex data structures back same
thing goes for algorithms you may think
that a a lot of beginners will start off
trying to implement something like a
star or a flood fill algorithm just to
do navigation yes right this is an
example from from work I'll explain what
exactly this one is but just just in the
overview like most N squared algorithms
are completely untenable in the bytecode
system so if you see it N squared
algorithm it's not going to work unless
you do something to it so there are
multiple ways you can distribute it
among multiple robots which is actually
very hard you can break up the
computation into multiple steps and run
a piece each turn which is hard
depending on the algorithm and then you
can also just run a completely different
algorithm
so the one I actually have up here that
this is a cute little example from our
old codebase it's not the actual
implementation but it's the algorithm
itself this is called a multiply with
carry it's actually a pseudo
pseudo-random number generator there's a
period there's like a period of like two
to the sixtieth but for all intents and
purposes it is a random number generator
we actually implemented this because we
noticed that math dot random on seeding
pays 144 byte codes and then each
subsequent get next energy recall is 80
and we actually wrote our own custom
random number generator to say 40 byte
codes per call to get next int and so
this this is the algorithm actually
pulled from Wikipedia we changed it a
little bit but in essence it's a bunch
of bit operators that gives you a pseudo
random number generator just to save on
byte codes and if you're if if you have
an algorithm that relies on a lot of
random numbers the 40 per get next
integer actually adds up there's
actually a tool a really nice tool that
we used a lot last year called dr.
garbage visualizer I don't know why it's
called dr. garbage because it's like one
of the best tools ever but uh what it
does is it actually it D compiles your
class into the actual byte codes and
then it shows the control flow graph on
the right so the control flow graph will
actually allow you to reason about where
your short circuits are happening
because if you short-circuit a code
block you're not actually paying the
byte code for what you don't execute
right so you'll want to terminate loops
in or you want to terminate loops early
you'll want to try to avoid code that
doesn't have to be computed multiple
times
in order to reduce your total byte code
count so by having the control flow
graph on the right it's actually very
easy to reason about how to save byte
codes especially when you'll see the
control flow graph plus the instruction
plus kind of a small comment about what
the variable is or what the method call
is or what the constant is
so so that's enough so ultimately with
by codes that the last thing I'll say is
if you're not sure test it we give you a
function called get by codes num and
this allows you to see what bytecode
number you're currently executing so if
I want to say profile a particular
function call I made or a particular
algorithm just surround it with two
system.out.print line get by Co Nome and
this will tell you the total number of
byte codes that your algorithm took to
execute and you can use this to kind of
profile it down you can try different
things but ultimately whatever gets that
number smallest is what helps your bot
when you're optimizing algorithms we
actually at the bottom this is a woops
this is a little loop that Earth this is
a little function call that we that I've
added at least every year at the end of
every robot's round it actually checks
the round number and the current by code
number to see if it went over by codes
and will actually emit a warning to to
the system console that it went over by
codes so actually it's it's really
annoying but it's really helpful if
every time a robot goes out for byte
codes it yells at you because then you
can play a match if you're not actually
like profiling something if you're not
actually explicitly saying that you can
sometimes ignore it because the byte
code number is just in the top right of
the client and you'll kind of miss it
sometimes you'll see like oh maybe it's
like 10k but like whatever but if like
your robot is yelling at you every time
it goes over 10k and your entire army
just like screams in the middle of the
battle use something that has to be
changed in order to make it so that
you're not you're not missing an attack
or you're not missing a movement every
turn that that you could be moving so
this year actually it's even more
critical because there are no cooldowns
every robot every turn can move so if
you go over by codes once that's a lost
movement which could translate to a loft
attack so it's very critical in battle
situations that you do not go over by
codes so you can get your movement and
I'll show you why a bit especially in in
micro situations so micro is really
important to attack micro I've been
emphasizing this over and over you
should know the execution order of the
robots or but you should know what
happens winds wind wind attacks happen
so what when do attack seven
at the end of the round right you should
understand like kind of the discrete
nature of the mat and and you should
know that micro is better than
everything else so I don't know if max
has covered this but in two robots which
robot actually wins the 1v1 engagement
it is yes it's the one who closes the
gap first is the one who wins the
engagement so if I have two robots two
squares apart right now it's it's a
stalemate
but if red makes the mistake to move in
what happens is blue closes the distance
and gets the attack off first and all
things being equal Rhett red will attack
second but blue has already done the
initial damage which means on blues turn
where he kills red red will not deal
back the corresponding damage to kill
blue blue will win so blue will have one
more robot in the next upcoming
engagement and therefore higher DPS and
would win the next battle this situation
is also particularly bad because red
can't actually retreat if red moves back
blue can still close the gap next turn
so understanding kind of how the micro
works in this game is actually very key
to winning engagements so in a 1v1
situation the gap closure always has the
advantage just just straight up so you
will want to write code that takes this
into account so that you can actually
win engagements in a 2v2 situation it's
a little bit more complex so what
happens into v2 so so red can move
forward blue can close the gap but red
can close the gap with the second unit
and now he's dealing twice the dps that
blue has and and will will eventually
win
blue blue can actually if blue is clever
blue can actually micro to focus fire on
a single unit because damage is split
evenly across all enemy robots so blue
can actually try to micro a little bit
to kill the bottom red unit if red if
red makes a mistake but red will
actually can move down and continuously
attack blue until the blue robot is dead
and the two v1 will win and if red
micros correctly he won't use this thing
he won't lose a single unit
so in a large fight or in larger flights
the larger army has the advantage given
correct positioning because you could
assume in this sort of scenario blue can
actually reduce this to a 1v1 fight if
red does not make the correct choices in
the subsequent like five or six moves so
so blue Ville will move up and attack
red and reduce it to a 1v1 scenario
unless the red robot can retreat
backwards while still attacking blue
towards the bottom red unit and continue
fighting so that they can turn the 1v1
into a 2v1
engagement so these these small like
discrete steps are what you should
actually be thinking about when you're
writing micro code
it's it's very critical that you don't
get indefinitely cutted like it's very
critical you do not write code that that
ends up in this scenario where you're
attacking and then you try to retreat
but you can't actually retreat in this
game because the opponent will close the
distance so there's only two scenarios
in which you can retreat you can retreat
if there's an army behind you willing to
back you up or you can treat if you're
retreating over a mine that gives you
more DPS so there's some team dynamics
things that I just want to cover this is
mostly geared towards the novices in the
room but make sure you guys are using
source control management I think this
goes without saying every MIT class now
emphasizes the importance of source
control and management and I'll even say
you should just use hosted source
control management so if you're using
git if you're using mercurial you should
just throw it up on one of these like
free hosted SCMS just because you don't
want to deal with like the server going
down so my first year we made the
terrible mistake of hosting our own SVN
server on an ex VM machine from Sippy
and then like randomly there was some
downtime that was uncontrolled and then
we'd have access to our code base for
like two days this was terrible
so just github these guys are like paid
to keep your source up okay so sip sippy
is not paid to maintain that your
battlecode source does not go down so
trust these large source control guys
and
especially trust distributed source
control if you guys are familiar I think
max gave a lecture on git so you use it
effectively and also figure out your SCM
your source control strategy so this is
actually a big one every team does their
kind of release cycle or I would say
release cycle but you're like releasing
bots a little bit differently so I'll
explain the way we did it we had a
single package called ducks just because
we really like ducks don't don't ask
we fork off a bot every time we release
it
so in our mainline ducks package when we
get to a state we're saying like this
this bots reasonable we want to submit
it to the server we'll actually copy the
ducks package rename it to our kind of
BOTS naming scheme which is based on sc2
AI levels if you guys play a Starcraft
and so we started off with medium player
so we'll copy the Ducks package into the
medium player package and what this
allows you to do is always have a copy
of the MTG player in your repository so
you can always pit your mainline bot
against any of the other heads you've
cut off from from the repository so some
teams like to do it differently I know
gun face in 2011 liked to use source
control tagging so what this allowed
them to do was they could update to any
version in the source control and they
could recompile it but the issue with
that is if you update you have to update
your entire mainline packaged backwards
you have to recompile it and then you
have to keep the class files around so
that you can pit them against your
current bots once you re update to the
current head this gets a little bit
annoying and for us it was just simpler
to persist like 30 or 40 copies of the
same file just in different packages
because it saves on time it's not
elegant but elegance doesn't really
matter that much when you're trying to
finish a button the short amount of time
that you have we actually went one step
further this is technically part of the
custom tools but we actually had a one
touch deploy system so we had a single
script that was responsible for building
the release tagging the release testing
the release on our automated mass
testing system and then cutting the
branch from mainline and pushing it back
to the repository this is very key
actually if you're doing what some of
you guys may have been doing last night
and trying to submit like 20 seconds
before the
because if something goes wrong you're
completely screwed so if you have a tool
that you know works and you know roughly
the amount of time it takes for it to
work its standardized and you're less
prone to human error so we ran the
script everything's done we have a jar
we upload the jar we're done and this is
reliable that we're not like manually
trying to create the zip file I know
some people have been having issues with
like BOTS randomly exploding or like
sometimes the submission works or
sometimes the submission doesn't work if
the whole thing is automated it's going
to work barring some catastrophic
failure this is also a random cute
little chip so I'm sorry for the stream
of conscious but just trying to like
mind dump as much useful information on
you this one I'm actually really
surprised I couldn't figure this out for
like three years how to deal with like
shared debugging so for those of you
guys working in teams you'll have like
print lines I'll have indicator strings
that like one day you'll be like testing
something and you'll merge in someone
else's poll and then you'll be like who
overrode my indicator strings because
now I don't know what I'm deep bugging
have any of you guys had this issue so
so you'll have like you you're like
debugging nav and you're like printing
out the current nav state or your
current state machines navigation
position and all of a sudden like the
guy working on a tack micro is over
wrote your indicator strings with like
current number of robots like attacking
you or whatever and this gets like
really frustrating really fast because
then you end up with merge conflicts
when people try to like change each
other's indicator strings like the guy
working on nav will comment out the
attack guys indicator strings and then
you end up with a merge conflict and
then you guys will screw up the merge
conflict and stuff will just like go to
hell so what we did was the bots can
actually read from the java bc config
and actually what we built was this
custom system this custom like debug
system that allowed us to specify who
was running the bot based on the current
Eclipse launch profile and only print
out indicator strings from the person
launching it so so you'll see on the
left like we made for custom launch
profiles one for me one for Justin one
for height and one for YP and when you
ran your custom launch profile it would
only display debug information
you're bought so you'd only see your own
print lines you would only see your own
indicator strings and then we like never
had a merge conflict well we did have
merge conflicts but not related to
indicator string setting so this is just
like a small little trick that just it
saves a lot of time because because
stuff stuff will add up oh the across
your total BOTS development time you
don't want to like spend time arguing
about people like like I know some teams
will say like okay you can only use
indicator string one I'll only use the
indicator string too but like someone
will need like two lines of information
then you guys like fight over it and
like really stupid
are there other generally useful advice
all the past teams have actually put a
lot of information on so there's some a
lot of stuff that I don't need to
reiterate so I don't know how how many
of you guys actually read the blog post
that I put on put on Hacker News so yeah
nice from 2012 to 2009 actually all the
old strategy reports all of the winning
teams are actually online so I have the
blog post from our team but there's also
a strategy report that corresponds to
that to our bots that's in our
repository the 2011 post mortem is
actually an excellent write-up by Steve
Ark Angela who wrote the math scram
tester about various other tricks you
can do to save by codes 2010 is by
Spencer skates on finding the shortest
path to victory it's kind of a their
their whole like bellman-ford pun team
thing that they had going on they detail
a lot of like high level mechanics that
help you when you're in combat they also
Spencer skates and Steve watch I'll also
one in oh nine and they they were called
g2g ice skating lessons which is it was
like an inside joke that none of us got
but um they wrote about their 2009
experiences as well they actually set
the trend of like the winning team
usually ending up writing the best
strategy reports which is a trend you
guys should continue
some other random tips messaging I'm
really excited about the new changes
this year because messaging is global so
what this allows you to do is you no
longer have to have robots really close
together so if you guys are familiar
with the 2011 game what you would have
to do is because you could only
broadcast eight squares away you would
have to send up a relay you had what you
had to set up a relay network of robots
that would propagate information
outwards and there's a whole amount of
overhead just associated with writing
the relay network that could get a
message from robot a to your entire army
like that that was like at least a day's
worth of work setting up the
rebroadcasting setting up the hashing
setting up all that code this year
because everything is a global message
board it makes it easier to broadcast
very important information very fast all
your robots but what this also does is
battle code has has a huge history of
message based attacks so it also makes
the message based attacks more
interesting because now the enemy very
easily can see everything you're writing
to the board so some some of the more
famous message attacks have been one
year you guys are familiar that the
robot VM limit is 8 Meg's right so if
you exceed 8 Meg's a robot actually
automatically implodes so one year a
team went around just broadcasting 8
Meg's arrays so the enemy team would
either get it try to process it and
completely freeze that get it try to
process it and explode immediately
because they like loaded it in a memory
or something stupid like that or they
would they would just stop moving
because they constantly exceeded their
at their bytecode limit then I think in
like oh seven teams we're trying to
exploit the fixed cost of array dot hash
code so array dot hash code used to be a
single byte code we used to that there's
a package in your distributable battle
code installer called method costs and
that explains the cost of every single
method that we don't explicitly list a
cost of or if a method is not listed in
there it's free unless it's in one of
the restricted packages but what
happened was array dot hash codes was
free so teams thought they were being
really clever by using the oh of one
hashcode caustic basically do a love n
algorithm to get entire hash code and
secure their messages that way but then
one team just took the fact that every
team was using a radio hash code and he
could mutate the array without changing
the value of the final hash and then he
would send that back to the robots and
all their robots would just like
completely mess up because they thought
the hash was correct but the data was
completely garbled which which was like
a really interesting messaging messaging
attack so you need to make sure when
you're messaging to check the integrity
of the data and make sure that the data
check the validity of the data and also
make sure that the data actually gets to
where it's supposed to go so this year
the most obvious attack of course is to
wipe the entire board and you can do
this every round if you have some
obscene number of generators like 30 or
so but the thing is you can pool energy
this year so actually a team that say
just wants to wipe the message board
during critical situations like during
an engagement can actually pool enough
energy so that they can wipe the entire
message board in one go so you can't
actually assume that what you wrote into
the message board one round will
actually be there the next round or even
between rounds because the robot the
enemy robot who executed between you
could have wiped it so make sure that
whatever messaging scheme you use
there's a way to check the validity
either by hashing and storing maybe like
the top four bytes as your hash or by
duplicating the information in multiple
places and checking that all the
information matches with each other but
as long as you can reliably get
important information over like if you
have like a retreat signal or like an
all-out attack so it'll just make sure
it's secured and it's at safely
propagated to all your robots here's a
random piece of advice keep your
frameworks lean especially with the byte
code limit you don't want to create this
beautiful like hierarchy of abstract
interfaces that just has like a ton of
intermediate layers before you actually
get to like the nitty-gritty code
because for every additional layer of
abstraction you're in
using the bytecode cost so actually one
of the one of the cool things that the
bytecode limitation actually enforces is
it enforces really lean code which is
not something you typically see in Java
so if you'll actually look at our class
structure this is from our 2012 bot we
have a very very flat class hierarchy
one because we just didn't want to deal
with extra sub packages and two because
there's really not too much to be gained
from like really elegant architecture
other than just wasting time because the
behavior code is ultimately what matters
so we wrote extremely lean frameworks so
this is actually our main run loop
you'll see here all we do is we reset
our internal timers we update a few key
round variables like the current time
and my current energy and the current
position of all the base bases and then
we run our message system we actually
run this we run the main run call which
would basically be a giant state machine
probably like five six to a thousand
lines long of just like completely messy
code that determines what the robot
wants to do and does it and then we
actually abstracted movement out this
was probably the biggest piece of
abstraction that we did was we moved a
movement out to a separate position
where we we knew that each robot was
reliably moving every single round
because it's very key that you always
move because that that that is an impact
on your total damage per second and then
we did some generic things and we also
had this this cute little thing down
here at the bottom which is if we had
some spare byte codes we would use the
extra byte codes for computation so
navigation last year was because there
were walls the algorithms you had to use
last year were actually quite different
basic team most teams would write
something called bug nav which you guys
from the navigation lecture I suppose
you discussed it a little bit where if
you see an obstacle you hit the obstacle
you try to trace around the obstacle and
then once you're free of the obstacle
you keep moving but then there's the
more advanced teams would actually write
a more complex version of bug nav which
is called tangent bug which is you
basically can project a virtual bug and
if you see you've rounded a corner
instead of going forward hitting the
wall and going around it
you can just cut the corner and we
actually used our extra bike codes to
pre-compute steps of tangent bug in
order to make our navigation maybe like
five or six squares better but that
better means you get to the enemy two
rounds faster because you cut a corner
and then two rounds faster means you
have extra DPS on the enemy and so your
when that when that initial engagement
this year because there are no permanent
walls bug nav and tangent bug may not
actually be some of the best algorithms
haitai might have kind of a little bit
running on but what the best nav will be
we're thinking it's probably going to be
some sort of very discretized flood-fill
algorithm or like a-star algorithm that
doesn't come try to compute every square
but actually breaks everything up into
discrete segments so you want to be able
to rush to the enemy base if they're
just a straight-up nuke but we guarantee
you around we guarantee you a minimum of
200 rounds if you follow the optimal
path but you have to know what that
optimal path is or you won't get to
there in time or Mac maximum of 200
rounds so our bets are actually on the
most advanced teams writing kind of an
a-star algorithm or a flood fill
algorithm that takes the map divides it
into discrete chunks so it doesn't
consider every individual square and
then it kind of picks sort of roughly
the best path to take so you can avoid
areas with more or less mines than than
the other areas and then this will still
get you to the nuke bot in enough time
without having to blow the entire cost
of the complete a star algorithm so a
star but and maybe like an eight by
eight or a ten by ten is tenable but
it's not tenable in 20 by 20 or 100 by
100 situations
this is kind of a big one don't don't be
afraid to write messy code I think it
speaks for itself but in case you guys
are like spending a lot of time like
trying to make beautiful code the thing
is what you ship is ultimately what you
ship that changes your boat's
performance is ultimately what matters
and a lot of beginners have this issue
where they're afraid to just hack
something together or hack a one-off but
to test but it's so key that you kind of
overcome this fear to write messy code
write stuff that works just get
something hacked out that's working and
then use that to to gain yourself an
advantage in what matters which is the
actual scrimmage the tournament matches
etc so we actually have code that's
that's terrible our navigation code
actually is completely on is not
understandable by the person who wrote
it anymore because it's so messy like
you can imagine bug nav for for anyone
who's tried to implement bug nav it
sounds really simple but they're
actually like hundreds or so of edge
cases that you have to account for so if
you end up bugging around another robot
or you end up in some sort of infinite
loop bug there's like there's a lot of
extra edge conditions that you have to
account for that that none of the
previous lectures have actually like
talked about at from like oh nine or
2010 or 2011 they'll just say like oh
yeah it's like bug now just like go
around the thing but what happens if you
have like two units bugging around the
same wall and then they hit each other
then one unit have to go around but if
one unit goes around and the unit on top
moves all of a sudden you have a unit
who's no longer next to a wall but
thought he was bugging around a wall but
he doesn't see any wall next to him
anymore and then your states get messed
up and everything just goes to hell so
don't don't be afraid to just right edge
case code that deals with that gets your
bot up and running so you can test like
the frameworks and the strategies and
everything that matters there's also
like last minute hacks actually actually
win games so I don't know if you guys
are familiar with our 2011 or 2012
championship but what we did was on the
very last day we were scrimmaging on the
server and we found out that the
second-placed scrim team team 16
had modified his attack code that I was
actually slightly better than ours and
because having better attack code means
you win the engagement it means he beat
our bot actually like three three times
out of four so we got actually really
scared about this and don't forget we
screamed this the day of the final
submissions so an hour before the
deadline me high tone why here it's
thinking about what should we actually
do so our ultimate hack was we actually
figure out what the team is by the
characteristic of their message
broadcasting so you're not actually
given the team number but if you look at
what kind of messages they're sending
you can kind of guess right and
throughout the whole battle code 2012 we
had been kind of like on the side just
like curious like looking at the
structure of other teams messages and so
an hour before the deadline submission
we wrote something that determined
whether the team we were playing against
was team 16 and we would change our
strategy and this was like an hour
before and was completely untested code
but we had been thinking about it kind
of in the back of mind and we just threw
this together we uploaded it and if you
were at the finals it was a pretty tense
match where we actually had a bug in
that code that triggered once and then
would not trigger a second time but but
that the one time it did trigger was was
like the very last match and so we we
ultimately won the final tournament but
this is like this is like a piece of
code incredibly critical it's like three
or four lines but it was the difference
between like first or second place so
once again it's like spending time where
it matters is like really key you can
probably do these sort of hacks this
year determining what the team is based
on the message structure is a little bit
harder because last year people would
send discrete message objects and so you
could count like the total number of
integers the total number map locations
whether it's like a secret key and then
you cook like correlate the secret keys
this year you'll maybe have to see like
how they like channel hop or what they
store in the various channels or kind of
like the channel distribution of the
different messages but it's it's still
possible so so last-minute hacks do win
games this is also another small one you
guys should all if you're not already
using IRC you should use IRC because all
the devs are on ours
especially us who are remote III was the
only person working on the engine who
was actually willing to fly out six
hours to give this talk so everyone else
is on IRC if you have any questions
should go on our IRC and you should
actually ask your questions so for those
you don't know there's there's a web
client just use the freenode web client
connect to channel battlecode ask
whatever questions you have
well we'll answer them pretty faster oh
pretty fast if you guys are feeling like
a little more advanced you should like
use IRC better if you actually persist
in the channel there's like a lot of
banter that goes on regarding um
game balance or like teams will like
discuss strategies or whatever so if you
actually like get a good IRC client and
stay in the channel you actually learn a
lot because sometimes it's some of the
old old battle code champions will just
come in just talk a little bit about
strategy or people just like discuss
like what they've been doing on the bots
etcetera so just just use like a good
IRC chat client like if you were to use
pidgin like pidgin has a built in IRC
client there's no reason to not connect
to it just talk to I'll talk to the devs
ask questions there's this been like a
lot of very simple questions but we're
more than happy to answer
so like questions about like round
number or if you have an issue with your
bot it's much faster than the forums
because will answer the IRC probably and
like in like minutes rather than hours
on the forum and most of all you guys
should just have fun like battle code at
least for us was it was a very fun
experience we we worked hard on it but
we also like we goofed off a lot like we
probably spent more than 40 hours
playing sieve 5 and before the Sprint
tournament or before like the cuales
tournament this is usually a bad idea
but it's about this is like IEP it's
about having fun
so we're card but also have fun and also
I have a few requests so there may
potentially be the 2013 winner in this
group so if it is one of you guys just a
few requests you guys should write a
good strategy report because battlecode
is not done in vacuum we learned from
the teams before us the teams before us
learned from the teams before them this
information really needs to be more out
Noah pin which is why I'm giving you
kind
brain dump of a lot of the very small
tricks tricks and tips that we did in
order to gain the competitive edge so
write a good strategy report help your
fellow competitors this is a friendly
competition it's not cutthroat you guys
can like make fun of all the other
lesser competitions but within battle
code like keep it give it a good family
and then join the devs if you guys win
because we need good devs so thanks so
any any like general questions or
whatever
once again yet it's it's our fault if
you guys like really hate nuke you
should say now yeah so there's also
another Star League team have a some
high hopes for the Star League guys
first year I did it with people from my
high school second year I did it I did
it with Star League people third year
was all startling people as well so you
guys should go to Star League if you
like Starcraft that's a pitch every
Friday 7 o'clock for 2:53 go go play
Starcraft it'll make your meta game
analysis better
any other questions bounce to general
comments so I'll be here afterwards if
you guys want to ask any questions if
you want to look through our old bot at
some point I will write up a code
walkthrough of our 2012 bot but until
then you just ask or we'll be in the IRC
channel or whatever so hopefully this
was useful to you guys so thanks